[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the top stories live for the Sky News
City Studio
crisis over the chief executive of JP
Morgan Chase plays down banking fears
after his rescue deal for First Republic
while HSBC reports that its profits for
the first three months of the year were
triple those of the same period last
year
strong oil and gas trading performance
helps BP beat Market expectations
and are we seeing the fund manager of
the future how AI could change investing
foreign
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City well while much of
Europe was enjoying a bank holiday
yesterday Americans were waking up to
news at another of its largest lenders
has had to be rescued california-based
First Republic which was the 14th
largest U.S bank at the beginning of the
year was seized by the FDIC the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corp after a run which
saw 100 billion dollars worth of
deposits taken out during the first
three months of the year well the FDIC
then sold most of the bank's assets and
its deposits to J.P Morgan Chase it's
the third lender after Silicon Valley
Bank and Signature Bank to require
rescuing in recent weeks I've been
speaking with Zoe Gillespie divisional
director at RBC Brewing dolphin and
began by asking her why First Republic
ran into difficulties
but we've seen in certainly the banking
sector in the US and certainly all over
has been pretty much dominated by the
fact that with interest rates now
starting to increase and we've seen an
outflow of deposits from some of these
Regional Banks which has led to some
stress on on the sector and I think
certainly what we have seen is through
March and there was a run-on deposits
for fresh Republic which has led to this
financial instability that's happened in
the bank was first Republic seeing a
deterioration in the quality of its loan
book
yeah I think we've seen the kind of the
quality
potentially more towards the depositors
leaving has actually been the problem
and obviously there's potential for the
quality if the housing market does start
to deteriorate so that there has been a
bit of a kind of mixture but mainly I
think it was it was the fact that the
data run on the deposits now the
business was being informally auctioned
for quite a while no one came forward
why did the US government decide this
weekend that it had to take action
well I think the theory was to try and
get something done before the market
opened on Monday to bring stability
um to the bank and I think certainly
what we have seen though is that
um generally this has just been a kind
of contained sort of incident and I
think from the banking perspective
um I think there was Keen to try and
sort of stop any kind of further
contagion in the sector so getting it
done was important people will be amazed
that this was the 14th biggest bank in
America at the beginning of the year
we've seen three rescues and Silicon
Valley Bank was the 16th largest should
people be concerned about the overall
health of the US banking system
um generally we feel that it has been
condemned and it's certainly to sort of
a few Banks rather than a banking crisis
that's starting to unfold has JP Morgan
got itself a bargain
time will tell
um and I think it's just going to be
interesting to see how they're able to
kind of shore up reserves and and I
think they'll they'll I think certainly
the moment
um they're taking on the liabilities as
well so there's there's potential for
for sort of
um kind of some I suppose better news
for them down the tracks are there other
U.S lenders that people should be
worried about
because see we just feel it's contained
to certain Regional Banks and I think
certainly this one seems to be the big
story and I think we've certainly seen
is that the drama of the banking sector
had been this dominated by this story
last week so I think yesterday the
market took the reaction quite well we
saw a very kind of muted response from
from the banking sector and from from
Wall Street so I think certainly it's
not something we think is going to
spread yeah and absolutely no read
across for the UK banking sector the UK
banking sector I mean today we've had
strong results from HSBC so um they've
tripled their profits and so that's
certainly been viewed very positively
this morning with the market so
um UK sort of banking sector seems to be
quite strong at the moment yeah I mean
the capital ratios uh we I mean for
example in that West on Friday I mean
they actually have more Capital than
they were targeting uh at this point in
time so they look relatively healthy
yeah so I think as you see I think it
does point to the fact that there's the
ones of Ganon it's showing that the
banks that have been better capitalized
and have actually been financially
better position have reported better
numbers and have actually been more
resilient and it certainly seems to be
contained to to more Regional banks at
this stage yeah we hear from Lloyd's
banking group later in the week what are
you expecting to hear from them well I
think the main thing I think we've had
some positive news stories from is in
that way snhsbc so potentially when we
see more seam again coming from them and
I think again I think it's going to be
the sort of for shareholders what the
dividend is going to be and certainly
any
um kind of if we're going to see kind of
a sheer BuyBacks or anything coming
through and just uh going back to First
Republic Marx ad attempt for the uh
authorities in the US they seem to have
done a pretty good job
I think they've done it quickly I think
I said I'm not sure but certainly the
way they've done it
um I think they were quick to act and I
think certain but they have managed to
to stay to the nerves and the banking
sector and as I say yesterday's reaction
Wall Street was muted which I think
shows you they've done a good job
well let's take a closer look now at
those HSBC results that Zoe referenced
there the bank has reinstated its
quarterly dividend for shareholders
after reporting better than expected
results for the first three months of
the year
well Europe's largest bank posted a
pre-tax profit of 12.9 billion US
dollars for the quarter that was more
than three times the 4.2 billion dollars
it achieved in the same period last year
and reflected an increase in the spread
between what it charges borrowers and
pays depositors the lender's profit was
also boosted on a one-off basis by the
reversal of a two billion dollar
impairment charge that it took against
its retail banking business in France
HSBC said this morning that that sale
May no longer now go through
and staying with another big set of
company results BP returned to profit
during the first three months of the
year after reporting a huge loss 12
months ago related to its exit from
Russia
while replacement cost profit which is
the recognized industry measure came in
at 8.7 billion dollars for the quarter
that compared with a loss of 23 billion
dollars in the same period last year as
the oil major wrote down the value of
its stake in the Russian oil and gas
company rosneft on an underlying basis
replacement cost profit came in at five
billion dollars that was down from 6.2
billion dollars in the same period last
year but up from 4.8 billion dollars in
the final three months of 2022 and
reflected what the company said was an
exceptional performance in its Gas
marketing and trading on BP said it
incurred taxes of 650 million dollars in
its North Sea business During the period
now confidence among small businesses
has rebounded strongly during the first
three months of the year that's
according to the latest survey from the
Federation of small businesses but the
organization warns that its members to
remain cautious for the remainder of the
year only two in five small firms expect
sales to increase during the current
quarter of what joining me now is the
national chair of the FSB Martin mctague
Martin welcome to you I mean I think
this is one of the biggest rebounds in
confidence we've seen from your surveys
what was driving that
well it was a really big rebound uh
we're still in negative territory but
the the people that I think did the best
were the ones that had suffered the most
during the covert crisis so you've got
rebounds with wholesale retail
hospitality and that's put us in just
marginally negative territory which is
still down on where we were this time
last year
Yeah you mentioned the headline number
is still marginally in negative
territory I mean I've also notice there
are some quite interesting disparities
between different groups within the
organization for example Professional
Services and Tech seems to be quite
positive compared with everyone else
yeah I think this reflects what we saw
during covet you know the the those
companies that are done well during
covid continue to do well and they're
driving that sense of positivity but you
know uh what I think is really
encouraging is you're now seeing those
businesses that really struggle during
covet starting to see those early
glimmers of Hope and uh recovery so a
good direction of travel then it's clear
though there are a lot of concerns about
overheads I mean labor costs in
particular remain uh difficult for a lot
of small firms and so do utility bills
yeah I don't you know the the end of the
uh Energy bill relief scheme uh was a
real disappointment for us and its
replacement is as good as useless
frankly and what we're seeing is a lot
of businesses that took out uh energy
contracts in the summer of last year now
trapped in really difficult conditions
we've asked the government and we've
worked with some of the big energy
companies to try and get what we call
blending extend which is essentially
allowing them to go for a longer term
contract that covers this really
difficult period we're getting some
positive reaction but still it's a long
way to go
Martin this is the first chance we've
had to chat since the uh cbi's uh woes
became uh very public there's a bit of
talk around about potentially bringing
together the various business
organizations like yourselves the
British Chambers of Commerce do you have
any thoughts on that
well we we have very different
constituencies you know the CBI are
largely uh represent the larger
businesses and uh we're we're clearly
focused on the needs of the 5.5 million
small businesses so I don't think it is
um rational or reasonable to say that
all the big four business organizations
can somehow blend together and represent
business as a whole we have clearly
different interests you've only got to
look at late payment where large
businesses consistently pay small
businesses ways that's something we need
to shout about and it wouldn't be easy
for a an organization representing all
of businesses and I take it to I mean
you obviously speak to your members a
great deal you've you've had no sort of
comments from Members saying look this
is time to uh get into bed with the
likes of the BCC and the CBI
now probably the opposite to be honest
Ian
um I mean I think I think there's a real
sense that the interests of small
businesses need to have a distinct voice
you know small businesses aren't able to
to buy big public affairs consultancies
to represent their view in government
they are able to use the likes of cbis
and provide them with a platform
small businesses need the FSB and we're
going to stay around
all right Martin got to leave it there
good to talk to you this morning thank
you thank you
green King the UK's biggest integrated
Pub operator and Brewer has reported a
share price in annual profits following
the bats back from the pandemic the
company which owns Pub restaurant Brands
such as chef and Brewer and Hungry Horse
reported a full year operating profit on
an adjusted basis of 192.6 million
pounds for 2022 that was up from one of
18.6 million pounds in 2021 when covered
restrictions were still in place for
much of the year the company whose beer
brands include green King IPA Old
Speckled Hen and abattail said trade had
returned to pre-pandemic Levels by the
spring of last year Well joining me now
is Nick McKenzie he's chief executive of
green King Nick good to see you this
morning that was uh 2022. what are you
seeing right now across the business
yeah look I think I think 2022 was a
really really solid year for us and and
it was achieved a guess against a pretty
challenging backdrop and you've
mentioned all that we had Omicron we had
strikes we had
issues around labor inflation and and
all East energy as well so I really
really uh challenging year but a really
really solid performance one which we
continued uh our investment program
continues to invest behind Our Brands
and our people and came out with a
really solid result returning to uh PBT
profit for the year I guess as we go
into this year
um you know the Outlook is still quite
challenging
also still a problem I think the good
news is on on some levels the consumers
stayed positive about coming out to the
pub and enjoying uh a pint or two uh but
we still have some some challenges to
face into as we go into 2023 and Beyond
you know I'm still pretty positive about
the long-term outlook for our sector but
I think the next sort of nine to 12
months still are going to be quite
challenging for us
what do you think in terms of input cost
inflation Nick I mean the headline
number has come down are you seeing
pressure starting to ease
yeah I mean the pressure's been been
pretty high over the last 12 or 18
months it has eased a little bit uh but
we still have the challenges around
energy we still have Labor inflation
um our labor cost inflation in our
business as well
um and food inflation is still high My
Hope Is during the course this year that
it will come down it will start to ease
but it's still putting quite a lot of
pressure uh and you've just talked about
this in the in the previous item around
small businesses that have been real
challenges around energy costs and we
need off German the governments and the
industry to work together really to try
and reduce energy costs for particularly
those smaller businesses over the next
few months from what you're saying Nick
I shouldn't be expecting uh a price of
my point of IPA to come down anytime
soon
although you can you can get great value
for that IPA
um across the country and there is still
great value out there for lots of
different of our products whether that
is food or whether that is on the drink
side as well I was just looking through
our menus earlier you can get any to put
Plastics in a Hungry Horse for 11 pounds
49 right now which is good value but
there is still pressure upward pressure
on pricing there is to look with
pressure that you know not just us many
others are having to deal with on on
price and whilst you you know you are
seeing price inflation there is still
good value out there if you look for it
you mentioned just now that you've been
investing in the business over the last
12 months you've also been making a few
Acquisitions you bought uh for example a
business in Scotland ubiquitous chip
yeah look we we've looked at possible
Acquisitions uh and we we still do
actually we continually look uh and we
look for businesses that fit our
strategy we look for businesses that
have great operations and and certainly
the the ubiquitous chip which is a
fantastic business
um up in Scotland uh has been been a
real strong addition to to our portfolio
we also invested in a business called
hickories uh 17 smokehouses mostly in
the North and the Midlands and we've
announced for new sites so we're
converting existing greeking pubs into
that brand and we'll continue to roll
that out and we have a fantastic
management team uh who were investing
behind who hopefully will take that
brand forward as well
what are your expectations for the
coronation Nick I know you've got a new
beer out to uh Mark the occasion
yeah we've proved a coronation beer uh
we brewed one back in 1954 as well uh
for Queen Elizabeth coronation uh it's
out there in 300 pubs it is fantastic uh
I've had a pints
um and hopefully people will enjoy it
over the coronation weekend we think
about 1.6 million more pints across our
estate uh we also think I think bbpa put
it out there 62 million more pints
across across the whole industry so it
is an opportunity for people to
celebrate in pubs a third of the
population have celebrated a major uh
National event in a permanent no better
place to do it than in a problem this
weekend we have lots of events going on
across all our businesses whether that's
tea parties or uh whether you know you
can do pretty much anything actually in
terms of those parties so lots and lots
going on and hopefully it'll be a real
welcome boost for not just us the whole
industry as well
Nickelodeon peers for example Marstons
have divested their their Brewing Arms
Why does it still make sense for you to
remain an integrated operator
yeah we're really proud uh of our beers
we're really proud of uh of what they
deliver and importantly obviously green
King RPA is one of our Major Brands and
we have green king
um across or above the door of many of
our puts so it is really important from
a brand perspective
um they are Market leading Brands they
we are we're actually uh in market share
growth during the course of last year so
in their own right they're really strong
Brands and and our Brewing Brands
business
um delivered a good profit for us last
year now it is challenging particularly
around Pascale
um and changes in and customer Behavior
around drinking CAF scale but we've
launched as you probably know a couple
of new uh premium beers this year
levelhead and flintside which are going
really really well so we'll we'll
continue to invest behind our beers and
Brands and they continue to be an
important part of our business all right
Nick good to hear from you I had I
actually had a point of habit yesterday
and very nice it was too excellent well
done thank you good to see you Nick
thanks a million thank you thank you
[Music]
to have a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial times
as you might expect leads its print
edition with yesterday's Rescue of the
US lender First Republic much of which
has been acquired by JP Morgan Chase
well the ft's columnist Megan green who
shortly to joined the bank of England's
monetary policy committee writes that we
can count on there being further Bank
instability as major central banks keep
rates High to fight inflation and Shrink
their balance sheets with the ft's
digital editions meanwhile are reporting
that investors are concerned that the
third seizure of a bank by U.S regulator
since March threatens to constrain
credit strain credit and worsen an
economic slowdown well the times also
leads with JP Morgan's acquisition of
most of First Republic but its business
front page also Cara's report that
alibaba's founder Jack ma is taking up a
teaching position in Japan as he begins
to reassume a public profile it suggests
that this mocks an end to his career as
an active businessman Daily Telegraph
also leads with First Republic and in
additional its front page it carries
details of report from the think tank
policy and practice which warns that the
Chancellor's decision to freeze the
level at which workers start paying 40
income tax at the list level until 2028
as well as the thresholds at which child
benefit starts and finishes being
tapered away means 180 000 families who
also qualify for Universal Credit face
effective marginal tax rates of 103
within five years well joining me this
morning is the sun's business editor
Ashley Armstrong Ashley good to see you
this morning so what's caught URI this
morning so yeah I mean obviously the
First Republic has dominated all the
headlines but there are two things that
caught my eye the first being um on the
front of the Ft actually we saw quite an
interesting thing about um PWC Nui
saying that uh actually they're young
joiners needed almost social skills
training to be brought up to speed and I
don't know about you I've had that from
all sorts of different Industries
particularly in Hospitality that
actually these new recruits because of
lockdown and the panda they were so used
to kind of being on their own and they
almost don't know how to kind of
problem-solve work in a team and I think
it's quite a kind of a frightening thing
when we're talking about kind of our
labor Gap shortages and our productivity
if actually there's a whole kind of
spread of younger joiners that aren't
able to catch up to the the level of
that what they're previously expected to
do I think that's going to make the
generational Gap and attitudes even
harder to kind of bring together and a
real challenge for employers really is
they try and sort of Re remote these
people yeah and I think and I think it
speaks a lot to kind of you know we've
spoken about workplace attitudes
changing right and I think if suddenly
you know you kind of get slightly older
workers even you know workers wage and
you're getting kind of uh new people
coming in and they are almost so
sheltered in terms of knowing how people
speak to each other or being told that
isn't a good enough job or how to how to
deal without without kind of almost
being in your parents supervision I
think that that's going to be like a
really tricky tricky situation do you
think that is just confined to the
pandemic generation though I mean if I
think back as a sort of old-timer of
newsrooms you know we used to pick up
the phone and talk to people everyone
seems to communicate via email these
days and what's that I don't know
exactly and I mean I'm still kind of on
the phone and you want and especially a
newsrooms you want that to to be that
overarching sound but I think yeah
you're right so many people are used to
kind of just only doing things by email
only doing things by WhatsApp and um
you're losing that skill of kind of
actually having a conversation as we
know you always get more from somebody
kind of by hearing the tone of
somebody's voice and and almost those
social cues aren't being learned online
yeah I thought that was quite
interesting talking to Mick Mackenzie
there about from Green King about uh his
expectations for the coronation are you
hearing much positivity around town well
I mean I hope so I think so I mean uh I
mean it's coming on the chart of another
bank holiday we've got one bank holiday
on the end so there is starting to be a
bit of a kind of like when are people
going to be in work but I definitely I
think the hospitality can do with some
real cheer and it's really needed let's
let's face it after kind of the the
waves of closures that they've had in
restrictions and but then we've also got
the kind of downturn and kind of hitting
people's spending I think actually you
know if people want that excuse and as
we know even though we're in cash strap
times people like to treat themselves
still yeah I mean it's funny if you
think back to 1953 in the coronation
then I mean you know there were some
items that were still on the ration so I
know I know well I mean sadly we might
be even going back into rations of some
things like you know I know that there's
been a bit of an outquire about quiche
being kind of like the the favored
coronation uh because actually eggs are
very short and and chickens are kind of
like the next thing on it but um but
generally I think we're going to be
having quite kind of a multicultural
kind of buffet that we're going to be
seeing across most households yeah
thinking about uh today's news how are
you going to be writing up BP's results
because I mean most of the price of
petrol is actually Government taxes it's
not it's not what BP makes I mean 100
and we kind of know that on the fuel
Duty actually you know the government
did very well when the when the price at
the pumps it was very high
um BP I mean it is a tricky one right
because look at their trading arm and
that is where they're making so much
money and even though there's been a
fall in the uh natural gas prices
they're still making a hell of a lot
from kind of trading that and that is an
arm that you know you can say
campaigners say there is
there's no kind of production there's no
kind of resource yes it takes a level of
Genius to make kind of a certain amount
of money on that but it's kind of
Commodities trading at the end of the
day whether it's windfall tax is hard
enough I mean we've seen the likes of
Harbor energy already saying you know
the UK is no longer attractive to being
investable uh we want BP to be investing
in this country but also it has made an
exceptional amount of profit and whether
um the wonderful tax could be used and
doing something else like Kirsten was on
the radio today saying use that to
freeze canceled tax bills it's it's very
political it feels like he spent that
windfall taxable times over already yeah
Ashley Godley there could see this one
thank you
a reminder to you to check out the Ian
King live podcast which you can find by
scanning the QR code on your screen
right now it's available now wherever
you get your podcast including the Sky
News app Apple and Google podcast and of
course Spotify
still here to come or near King live
we're gonna have a look at how the
markets are doing this Tuesday morning
don't go away
[Music]
thank you
independent United Kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
foreign
s have been driven by politics by
politicians the people in power you must
stay at home and it's my job to figure
out how these decisions made by
politicians impact all of us in our
everyday lives this is the worst thing
I've ever been through in my life people
turn up here with their child's stuff in
a black sack and just say I don't want
to and that is what it is it's first
class poverty is this an example of the
welfare state failing we take you to the
heart of the stories that shape our
world these are stories that affect us
all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians the real power
lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Music]
well stocks in the asia-pacific region
had a largely positive session overnight
only Sydney was the only major Market in
the region in fact to show a loss on the
session Tokyo finished slightly higher
ahead of the three-day public holiday
for Golden week in Europe stocks are
largely trading to the downside this
morning here's the current pitcher main
indices in Europe all in negative
territory apart from the MIB in Milan
that's ahead of interest rate decisions
later this week from the U.S federal
reserve and the European Central Bank
talking points today include Electrolux
the shares are up four percent in
Stockholm amid reports of a possible
Chinese takeover approach well here in
London the ftse 100 is largely unchanged
so look at that it's one and three
quarter points to the good there BP is
dragging on the index it paired back
share buyback gains and that has been
enough to clip 20 points from the index
on its own so the index would be 20
points higher in the absence of BP on
the upside well HSBC added some 23
points to the index following its
results HSBC they're up nearly four and
three quarter percent right now
elsewhere among the Blue Chips the plant
and Tool High group hash dead its Shares
are ahead by some two and a half percent
and that's after it launched a new share
buyback program worth half a billion
dollars outside the footsie the car
parts make a down late is ahead by some
five and a half percent let's
shareholder register continuing to
settle down following its recent
demerger from Melrose group on the
foreign exchange markets well it's quite
quiet again ahead of interest rate
decisions this week you can see Sterling
is off a third of one percent against
the dollar tenth of one percent against
the Euro The single currency meanwhile
off a fifth of one percent against the
Greenback as for the oil price well that
rallied yesterday while uh European
markets were shut it's given back some
of those gains today about a Brent crude
will currently set you back 79.20 about
that's off a little over a tenth of one
percent for joining me this morning is
the senior Equity Analyst at investec
wealth and management doctor Jimmy
good to see you this morning we're
halfway through uh the earning season
what do you take away so far well it's
been a pretty good earnings season much
better than expectations
um over 80 percent of companies have
exceeded admittedly low expectations but
what we've learned is that the economy
remains resilient we've been waiting for
a recession that has yet to come but the
Outlook is um is not set by any means
there is still a lot of uncertainty out
there do you think people are a bit too
I mean clearly they were people were
obviously pessimistic going into this
earnings season why do you think they
overdid the pessimism U.S in particular
yeah indeed um a lot has been going on
in the U.S particularly around the
banking terminal side of things
inflation has proved to be quite sticky
what came after corvid were supply chain
constraints we've had a lot of
um labor shortages which has resulted in
a cost of living crisis as well so a lot
of moving Parts have meant that
expectations have been coming down but
what we've seen is that companies have
proven to be resilient the consumer is
proven to be resilient and companies
have also done pretty well even though
they issued very cautious Outlook
statements and one of the things that
you've been looking at quite closely is
Healthcare Fair bit of M A going on
right now indeed M A is a very strong
Tailwind in healthcare in fact in these
uncertain times one is looking for
Quality defensive assets and healthcare
does stick all those boxes it's cheap it
provides a nice dividend yield and then
you've got this m a Tailwind coming
behind it and it's really driven by
three things number one is that by take
companies which tend to be the targets
of the big Pharma companies are cheap
thanks to the interest rate tightening
cycle the second thing is that there is
very strong Innovation there and Pharma
needs to infill their pipelines uh
heading towards the mid decade patent
cliff and then finally
there is a lot of pent-up demand you
know many pharmaceutical companies
benefited from covid-19 cash windfalls
and so their balance sheets are very
strong right now and what you tend to
find is unlike big Tech
um big big pharmaceutical companies tend
not to run into the risk of regulatory
headers when it comes to M A yeah very
interesting to note actually we've just
had results in the last week from GSK
and AstraZeneca both did pretty well
indeed
um AstraZeneca is very strong Innovation
coming down the pipeline it has got
medicines that are looking at changing
the Paradigm treatment therapies in
breast cancer and the big one coming in
few months time is a medicine for lung
cancer now lung cancer is a very
difficult cancer to treat but this is
this medicine has got very high hopes
glaxa Smith Klein has been going through
a difficult period where his pipeline is
still at the show me stage but you know
it's HIV business it is vaccines
business are doing pretty well I like
that the show me stage Jimmy good to see
you this morning thank you thank you
very much
still to come here on Ian King live but
we've got a bit more business news for
you first or with super dry Mark
Kleinman broke a story on that company
on Friday and we've had more news from
them today stay tuned for more
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go
welcome back now the big Trend in fund
management over the last decade also has
been for money to move from active fund
managers to so-called passive fund
managers that simply track an index or a
basket of stocks in a particular sector
but now the active managers potentially
face a fresh challenge funds managed by
artificial intelligence the fund
consisting of 38 stocks chosen by chat
GPT has in the last seven weeks
outperformed the average of the UK's 10
most popular funds that was in an
experiment conducted by the comparison
website finder.com well joining me now
is the chief executive of finder.com
John Osler John welcome to you what did
you instruct GPT when you were
constructing this portfolio yeah it was
really just a bit of a fun experiment to
see what new technology could do so we
we just fed it the um sort of General
investment principles that we picked up
from the top funds in the UK fed those
in and then asked her to put together a
portfolio which after a little bit of
negotiation we managed to extract those
those 38 stocks so it was up 1 point
seven percent versus down 1.6 for the
popular 10 funds was that performance
from the active funds distorted by one
or two of them doing especially badly
well yes I guess it did pick it did pick
more of the sort of NASDAQ um U.S stocks
so we had some Microsoft and meta in
there as well which typically had a good
had a good run over the last eight weeks
something went up five percent versus
down point eight on the top 10 funds in
the UK which maybe some of those a bit
more conservative indexes right so those
those are the things that made the
difference and it was mainly U.S tech
stocks yes yeah just some of the some of
the classics that uh I guess have
recovered over the last eight weeks but
uh by picking stocks sometimes it's more
chance than uh than logic but I guess it
was just really the uh the experiment of
seeing what what you could do with this
sort of Technology could it be said then
that if you've done this this time last
year when obviously tech stocks had a
pretty terrible 2022 the active fund
managers might have actually
outperformed Chachi PT at the moment I
would not recommend using chat GPT for
your Investment Portfolio
um but I guess in the future when um
these sort of AIS are connected to more
live data streams and especially if
you've got bespoke data that you can
feed into these models that's when the
real the real challenge comes for funds
as far as how they're constructed and
managed going forward and did chat GPT
churn its portfolio did it uh sell
stocks and buy others during the course
of this experiment unfortunately at the
moment it's it's it doesn't have access
to that live information unless you're
sort of on the beta development program
have hooked it up to something so this
was more just the general underlying
investment principles uh that will use
the select the stocks rather than
trading which you know ai's been used
for a long time for technical trading
and I guess this is more sentiment
trading now you've highlighted how it
did against the 10 most popular funds
how did it do against stock indices more
broadly
well it's definitely yeah it's
definitely up against most of the most
some of those indexes were just trackers
of um so definitely up a lot against the
foot C and things like that
um but uh yeah it did pretty well five
percent over the last eight weeks but as
I said you know what that's going to
look like in the future when when it's a
lot more capable
um that's going to be an interesting
space to watch yeah I mean the telegraph
carried out this experiment in February
and it's chat GPT portfolio actually
fell by 24 I mean I guess it depends
what you're asking this thing to look at
as I said stock picking is a difficult
uh difficult Beast to do and uh yeah
certainly it would require a little bit
more intelligence to the artificial
intelligence to to Really succeed over
the long run but uh yeah it's uh it's
gonna be fun to watch all right John
gotta leave it there good to see you
this morning thank you thanks
some of the day's other business news
stories for you now and the owner of the
wagamama and Frankie and Benny's
Restaurant chains said this morning that
its current trading continues to be very
encouraging the Restaurant Group which
owns 410 restaurants and Pub restaurants
throughout the UK set sails at wagamama
during the 13 weeks to the 2nd of April
were up by nine percent on the same
period last year on a like-for-like
basis when the benefits of last year's
temporary reduction in vat was stripped
out they were up some 10 percent in its
pubs on the same basis and up three
percent at Frankie and Benny's well the
shares I can tell you have jumped by
more than 10 this morning
the fashion retailer super dry confirmed
today it's in talks with investors over
a possible sale of new shares the
clothing brand confirming a story broken
by Sky's mark clyman on Friday evening
said the new shares being issued could
represent up to a fifth of its existing
Capital base it said that Julian Duncan
its founder and chief executive intended
to significantly participate in the
equity raise and provide a material
underwriting commitment which it said
reflected his confidence in the
long-term prospects for the business the
shares are done currently by some two
and a half percent
we're returning now to the theme of AI
and it's being suggested that technology
is distorting the benefits of exercise
by generating images that portray people
who engage in healthy exercise as those
with extreme physiques and that in turn
may be putting people off exercise by
causing them to develop worries about
their own bodies when they don't end up
with the kind of unrealistic physiques
seen in some images well joining me now
is the AI expert Omar Kareem Omar
welcome to you what evidence do you have
for this
um so what's really interesting is AI
the way that it's trained basically has
learned from all of the images that
we've put on the internet and what that
means is now ai has basically taken on
all of the existing biases so when we
generate images with AI they invariably
can result in you know impossible
12-pack ABS chisel jaws and really
things that that you know research shows
you know 72 of Brits find very uh
they'll end up in inferior to them so
yeah so this isn't just sort of nonsense
that people see on love Island and
things like that just it's imagine that
but physically impossible for humans to
achieve so there's just a it's beyond
what anything that we could do so yeah
how problematic do you think this is
going to be in years to come I mean if
you imagine we have you know it's taken
us years to get past stereotypes what
this might end up doing is it might
industrialize that sort of level of
inequality of what is achievable by
humans and what isn't yeah I mean this
is basically airbrushing isn't it
honestly it really is and what's really
frightening about this level of
airbrushing is it's take the human isn't
involved in the process so it's what the
machine thinks is the ideal human body
shape do you think healthcare
professionals and indeed
you know physical exercise professionals
are they geared up to sort of tackling
this
um you know what I think it's it's as
we're sort of like moving into this
space it's our responsibility to help
the AI really gauge and understand what
real exercise looks like so then
professionals can hurt Beyond with the
right images to really make that right I
mean you've been doing some work with
the sportswear manufacturer Asics to try
and Tackle this what sort of things are
you suggesting to them so it was really
the the project we did with the Asics
was very much about like AI is trained
in um where it's shown a bunch of images
and it understands what exercise looks
like with Asics what we tried to do was
actually show it images of thousands of
normal people doing exercises so not
airbrush people not Photoshop people but
regular people who go for a jog in the
park and go to the gym and stuff so
hopefully with that it will allow us to
have a program that will allow any other
AI company to take on all these images
and help make their AI it's a little bit
more normal
let's hope so yeah well good to see you
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live
we're going to be discussing why so many
listed companies are attracting bids to
go private don't go away
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power you must stay at home and it's my
job to figure out how these decisions
made by politicians impact all of us in
our everyday lives this is the worst
thing I've ever been through in my life
people turn up here with their child's
stuff in a black sack and just say I
don't wanna and that is what it is it's
first class poverty is this an example
of the welfare state failing
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
real power lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Music]
thank you
Global insight
made local
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
thank you
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back now we've talked a lot on
this program about the war for talents
and how businesses are having to offer a
more appealing workplace environment to
get employees back into the office and
those attitudes are more striking the
younger workers are today brings more
evidence of that with a survey
suggesting that gen Zed workers those
born between 1996 and 2010 are most
likely to demand enhanced well-being
sustainable and digital benefits in the
workplace and that includes an on-site
cafeteria well that research was carried
out by mintel for Compass Group for
joining me now Shelly Roberts the
company's group Chief commercial officer
Shelley welcome to you I mean what
struck me was lots of so much of that
it's the fact that across all age groups
people are demanding more enhanced
benefits
that's right Ian it was really
interesting to us as well so this survey
was conducted across 35 000 workers in
many different workplaces offices
manufacturing environments and across 26
countries and what we found was that
actually they're less loyal in
comparison to pre-covert in relation to
the relationship they have with the
employer they're also wanting their
employer to invest in them in terms of
their health and well-being and they're
scrutinizing non-monetary benefits more
than they ever have before now if we
talk about generational differences I
mean it was striking that gen Zed
workers feel more productive after lunch
that's right yes 81 of them reported
that after a lunch break they feel more
productive and they're also asking for
really healthy options in the workplace
that's helping them overall with their
mental health and well-being and when
they come into the office they're really
wanting to have a place where they can
socialize and I think you know that's
some of what we're seeing and what
they're reporting back is it's not just
of course the food they're eating but
it's that moment to take a break connect
socialize with people in the workplace
and that's the benefit of to mental
health yeah you also picked up on
differing generational attitudes towards
subsidized canteens and restaurants in
the workplace yeah so overall everybody
said I think it was about 81 of the
respondents said that their support
um a offer in the workplace and I think
you know much of this has to do with the
cost of living as well you know
employees are looking for free or
subsidized food in the workplace because
of the pressures they're seeing in their
grocery bills at home like we've seen
today in the market report and so really
um you know they're looking for for that
as an opportunity I think then we've
seen an acceleration of other trends
like for example wanting employers to
engage and promote sustainable choices
in the workplace which were there before
covert but they're really just
accelerated post covert now you of
course are the world's biggest contract
caterer I mean it's in your interest
that people say this you weren't leading
uh the people who have surveyed at all
in this well actually our reason for
doing the survey was that our clients
ask us this question because as you said
in the intro they're really trying to
understand the cohorts better the
employee groups better so they can
better attract and retain but also to
motivate their existing employees and so
they were asking us this question and so
we thought we'd go out and get some
Empirical research from a very well
respected research organization across
many dimensions Beyond food you also
picked up on some interesting views on
meat-free eating tell me about that yes
so particularly the Gen Zed but also the
Millennials and then even more so here
in the UK the Millennials are one of the
most vocal employee groups who are
asking for meat-free options in the UK
and they're very much wanting to to have
the opportunity to try out different
things and form new habits that must
make life a difficult for you though
because presumably there is going to be
a set to the workforce and if they if
they come in early they're still going
to want a bacon sandwich after they've
come off their shift well that's the
opportunity that we see because every
workplace has obviously a different mix
of these employee groups and so we
tailor our service to each of those
workplaces and what the survey does is
allows us to better understand those
consumers so that we can meet
everybody's needs in the workplace as
you say this was a survey that you
carried out right across the world where
did attitudes differ much from country
to Country yeah I think certainly here
in the UK many of the trends are Global
but here in the UK we see the
sustainability Trend being particularly
pronounced and that's really where
employees are asking their employer to
play a part in educating making better
choices to make better choices for the
climate and for the environment
obviously you've got a lot of these big
U.S tech companies among your clients I
just wonder whether they might be most
switched onto this as well more so than
say a bunch of workers on an oil rig
so we did the survey across Tech across
banking manufacturing environments and
actually we didn't necessarily notice
discernible Trends across those
different cohorts more so across the
generations as we've been discussing
today so if you had to distill all this
down into one key piece of advice for
clients what would it be I think really
to listen to
to understand the demographics in each
of these cohorts tailor the services so
that you're meeting everyone's needs
across those demographics all right
Shelly got to leave it there good to see
you this morning thank you
one of the big themes in business this
year has been the sheer number of listed
companies attracting bids from private
Equity firms looking to take them off
the London Stock Exchange well they
include the oil services and Engineering
Group John Wood the events and
conferences organize a hive and the
payments processor Network International
however there is a lot of Buzz around
the city that there may be more to come
and it's worth pointing out of course on
Friday there was a takeover that was
public to public Deutsche Bank
announcing the Takeover of numis
Securities we're getting more from me
now on the public to private team is the
co-founder our managing director of Dean
Street advisors Mervin Metcalf Mervin
good to see you this morning so why
public to private transactions so in
Vogue so I think if you look at from a
private Equity perspective they get to
buy a company where they can try and
dictate the strategy and work with
management to create a new opportunity
from their perspective it's a new deal
it's the primary deal so when they go to
their investor base they can say we've
created value for our investors from a
public market perspective from a
management team of a public company
frankly anything below a billion pounds
right now it's not really I think
getting real value from being a public
company there's a lot there's a lot less
liquidity there's a lot less capital in
the market so from a management team
trying to deliver a strategy it's much
harder and I think just from that point
if you're looking to change your
strategy and change a new direction do m
a i think it's a much harder thing to do
in a public environment whereas in a
private environment it's much easier to
execute that strategy absolutely I mean
we are in an environment however where
the cost of capital has been rising a
public a private Equity firms having to
work harder to make the numbers stack up
for them yeah look I think that's a very
fair comment um there's a lot of debt
funds that have Capital to actually fund
these transactions pricing I think it
all goes through to pricing basically
cost scaffold goes up your ability to
pay more for a company is much more
limited but I'd say there's still enough
demand in terms of private Equity
Capital looking at situations to put
money money to work now we're all
beating ourselves up here in London
about the fact that public markets seem
to be in a bit of a funk but it's worth
pointing out I mean there have been lots
of take privates right across Europe and
the United States as well this isn't
just a UK phenomenon no I think it's
across the board I'd say the UK is
probably more interesting to the public
to investors at the moment in terms of
opportunity more a function that the UK
Market is less liquid as I said than
there has been in the past but
interesting quite a lot of situations
we're looking at people are thinking
take the company private here maybe grow
it build it through M A and potentially
re-listed in the US market that's really
interesting I mean I guess arm Holdings
might be an example of that really yeah
that's fascinating what about the
attitudes of the CEOs themselves I mean
obviously
life is quite hard if you're a public
company CEO your salaries are in the
newspapers and people poke and prod at
you yeah look I think uh every uh
situation I've seen where someone's gone
private they reckon management teams
have saved almost half their time not
being on the public market in terms of
doing quarter results talking
shareholders and actually in a in a
private environment you have one
shareholder effectively that's aligned
with you so actually executing your
strategy is much easier in a private
environment and do private Equity owners
tend to be more relaxed about things
like executive pay I mean there's been a
big rare for example in the last week
over Andy bird at Pearson yeah look I
think from their perspective that
everyone's aligned to create value so if
if the management team are creating
value then they're very happy for them
to make value from that from that
purpose so is this a problem for the
institutions that manage I mean we know
that there's been a big loss of interest
in UK equities from the institutions
I I look I think from an Institutional
perspective they've had a lot of capital
leave their their Capital base so
actually someone coming along
potentially making an attractive offer
for an asset gives them some Capital to
pay back to their institution so it's
not necessarily all bad news and
actually from a from a context of a
wider Market there's still not that many
public privates public privates being
looked at I'd say brought about people
like us that you know we're the man on
the street they saw retirement savings
that these institutions are managing
most a lot of that money has been
shifted into bonds are we potentially
missing out on our performance as a
result of that I believe but I suspect
some of your your pension money is also
in the private Equity Community as well
you may not know it absolutely yeah um
what about the private Equity
institutions themselves that do you
detect a lot of confidence on their part
so I'd say if I look at the meetings
I've had this year not that many funds
have really worried too much about the
underlying Market condition they're
worried about the banks going under in
terms of you know there's a potential
financial crisis coming up but I think
that stabilized a lot more but I think
from a from their perspective they're
looking at a four five year time Horizon
so they're not looking at necessarily
the next three months it's a much more
what can we do with this asset to create
Valley and the key point is as far as
you're concerned there's more of this to
come these business these firms do have
money to spend right now yeah I think
last year was characterized by a lot of
the big funds fundraising a lot of the
big funds now have billions of capital
of free powder
where do you think the activity is going
to be are there individual sectors where
valuations are particularly bombed out
that you'd be looking at I'd say I'd
probably do a negative so I think
anything consumer related is much more
tougher right now for obvious reasons
but if you're a business B2B service
provider text Tech enabled solution
Business Financial Services
interestingly is still quite active
those are types of sectors I think uh
private Equity are very focused on what
sort of rating typically would something
have to fall to for private Equity to
sort of pop up and think right well we
must have a look at that is is it is
that too sort of broader yeah I'd say
that's too broad I think it's much more
what's the underlying company and what's
the opportunity you're doing it so the
the whole concept of asset stripping is
not what they look at it's much more
about it's a good base it's very
important to have a good management team
and what can that team do with more
capital and I'd say again on the public
market a lot of public companies I think
are restrained in terms of capital so in
a private environment you know you can
have you've got a good base you know
consolidate expand internationally
that's basically what the private Equity
guys are trying to do all right it's a
fascinating topic Marvin it's great to
have you talking about it today thank
you
that's it from me I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning but in the meantime
there's plenty more on the Sky News
Mobile app and on the website with
reporting video content and Analysis
from our business team well do stay
tuned after this short break it's Jane
sucker up thanks very much for joining
me today cheerio
foreign
[Music]